[MUSIC PLAYING]
ANKUR KOTWAL: Good
morning, everybody.
And for those of you that are
watching online, good evening,
good afternoon, wherever
you are around the world.
Thank you for joining us today.
My name is Ankur Kotwal, and
I'm on the Google Maps API team.
So the Google Maps APIs have
been around for over 10 years.
It's one of Google's first APIs.
And in that time, we've
added a lot of functionality
to these APIs.
And sometimes that's meant
introducing new APIs.
Sometimes that's meant
adding these capabilities
within existing APIs.
That's led to an interesting
challenge, actually.
So if you look here,
we have a lot of APIs.
And we support the
web, Android, iOS.
We have a number of great
web services to help you--
to help provide data to each
of those platforms as well.
But some of the feedback
that we've had from you
is this functionality is
great, but it's a bit daunting
to get started.
Right?
How do I-- how do I look at this
and go, OK, what are the things
that I'm going to need for
my business, my use case?
It's kind of a nice
problem to have,
but even if you're
not new to us,
if you're a seasoned
Google Maps API user,
you probably have faced this.
And we publish blog posts
and release notes and videos
to try and keep you up to
date, but it can be daunting.
So if I took a different
analogy, up until now,
we have been giving you the
tools and the components
and some instructions to
help you piece together
your software solution.
To take that metaphor
further, if you're
thinking of your software
solution as a lounge room,
we were helping you build those
components, the parts that
go in the lounge room.
A drawer, a table, a couch.
Today what I want to do is
talk to you about something new
that we're doing in addition
to providing you these APIs.
We call them solutions.
And in this case, we want to
provide you the lounge room.
We want to provide you a
reference implementation
to help get you started with the
best of breed maps application
depending on your use case.
And we're going to make
it entirely open source.
We're publishing it
on our developer site,
along with supporting
documentation,
so that you can
grab this and say,
you know what, I want
to change the color,
or I want to swap one component,
one of my software components
out with something else.
But your starting
point is a great one.
And even if you have an
existing application,
you could maybe borrow some of
the features or capabilities
that we are adding
to these solutions.
So let's move on to talking
about these solutions.
As my team went to start
building these out,
we started to come up with
different architectures
that we would have for
different Maps API uses.
And the one thing that
we kept coming back
to that was sort of defining
what our architecture would be
was location data.
So depending on the
type of data you have,
would dictate what kind
of architecture you use.
And so broadly speaking, we had
three types of location data.
Static data-- data that
doesn't change very often.
We had dynamic data
that does change,
that maybe you have things
like user-generated content
where you want to show photos,
or in the case of a real estate
application, more houses
are coming on the market
or being taken
out of the market.
And then you have
real-time data, as well,
for things like tracking
vehicles in real time.
And then as we started to build
that out, we came up with a way
to split that
static data use case
into two, one which is
entirely just client-side.
You don't need to have a
server beyond your web server.
So today's talk, we're going
to go through these solutions.
We've built these out.
We've published them.
And we want to
share them with you.
And hope to jump-start
your development.
So the first one we're
going to look at is a--
the static data, the client-side
only example, and it's
the Coffee Shop Finder.
This is a very common
scenario for a store locator.
We've come up with a
fictional coffee shop called
Josie's Patisserie and
Cafe, and Josie basically
has a successful
business in the UK.
She's got a number of stores.
And often that data
doesn't change, right?
She's got a fixed
number of shops.
She may have a new
store opening up,
or their opening hours
and closing hours
might change depending on
seasonality or holidays,
but effectively, there's
not a lot of change there.
So what we're going to do
is look at a quick demo
of Josie's Coffee Shop Finder.
And so if we can
shift to the laptop--
that's great.
So here we're just
showing you the map.
We don't expect that your whole
website or app would be just
entirely the map, but you can
see the map section of it,
and that's what we're going
to cover in the solution.
So the first thing you notice
is that it is a Google map,
but it looks different.
It's because we've
used a custom style.
We've muted the
colors a little bit,
and we've aligned it more
closely with Josie's brand.
So let's have a look at
Josie's Liverpool patisserie.
And immediately you see
some text that says--
describes the store.
It shows the opening hours
and some contact details.
Probably my favorite feature
is the image, though.
We're using the
Street View image API
to show you what
the shop front looks
like so that when
customers are going
to come to the actual
destination, they can see it.
Let's switch to a cafe,
Josie's Cafe in [? Oakham, ?]
and again, similar data.
This is a very basic
Store Locator app,
but I want to show
you how we built it.
So let's switch back
to the slides, please.
If you look at the architecture
for this particular example,
it's really, really simple.
We have three files that are
just sitting on a web server.
And this is that
client-side only code.
You'll notice we have the web
page, the index, the HTML.
We have a JavaScript
file and a JSON file.
That contains the
data for the stores,
and I'll show you
why that's important.
Actual implementation of this
is actually very, very simple.
We're going to
initialize the map.
We're going to put all that
data on it and style it.
And then we're going
to add a click listener
so that when users
click on the marker,
we populate it with the
relevant information.
So in terms of
initializing the map,
for any of you that
have used the Maps API,
the JavaScript Maps API before,
you'll be familiar with this.
We added div on
there, which is a map,
and then we add an asynchronous
script to go and load
the actual Maps API.
So that URL will be
very familiar to you.
We substitute API_key
with our API key.
We lock it down so it's
only useful on our domain,
so people aren't
using our API key.
But the important thing is we
have this callback parameter
on the right-hand side.
When the map is
loaded, it's going
to call back our init function.
And we're going to go ahead
and initialize the map.
We're just going to
set the zoom level
to what we want it to be set
to, the latitude and longitude,
and apply our style.
Very, very basic.
Now remember I said that
we have a JSON file.
Well, that JSON file
contains all the store data
so that we're just following
programming best practices,
separating our data
out from our code.
And by using GeoJSON,
which is an open standard
for geographical data, it means
that we just have a simple JSON
file that's structured
in a particular way,
and loading that JSON
file onto our map
gives us some advantages.
So advantages like
pre-populating the map
with the data,
applying marker styles,
and even attributing
that metadata.
So in code, when we
need to refer to fields,
it'll just do it for us.
But my favorite part
of using GeoJSON--
to put that data on a map,
it's a single line of code.
Our Maps APIs support this.
You just say
map.data.loadgeojson,
take that store
file, and it's done.
Just wanted to give
a quick demonstration
to what the structure
of that file is like.
You don't need to look
at the details here.
As I said, we've
open sourced this,
so you can have a look at it
in greater detail offline.
But that's it.
That's what GeoJSON gives us.
Now we're going to go look
at the event click listener.
And the way we add that
is we tell the map, hey,
we want to add a click
listener, and it's
going to execute this code.
I've put some ellipses
in there to get rid
of some of the boilerplate
code, but basically,
we're going to initialize some
local fields, and that info
window, that speech
bubble that we saw,
it's just-- when we set content
in there, it's just HTML.
So the way we had laid out those
images, the Street View image
API, it's just general HTML
that we're populating it with.
And the reasons that source
over there is particularly long
is because that's how we're
calling the Street View image
API.
And we're saying,
here's our API key.
And then for each
of Josie's stores,
we're saying, here's
the latitude, longitude,
so go and fetch us that
particular Street View image
and put it in line.
But it's as simple as that.
We didn't have to go and like,
do a look-up as to which marker
corresponded to which data.
Because we used GeoJSON,
that attribution
was already done for us.
It's really, really neat.
And then the last
thing that we do here
is just go ahead and position
the info window and open it
so that it displays.
So here in this simple
store locator example,
we used a JavaScript API and we
used the Street View image API.
But the cool thing is we
didn't need a server-side,
like a back-end to power this.
And this would
actually fit really
well for many store locator
examples that I've seen.
So let's take it one
more step further.
What about in the
situation where
we have got more
data, where we do
need a server-side component?
And for this one, we're going
to have a look at the New York
City Subway Locator.
So in New York City, there's
many, many subway stations,
so there's a lot of data.
You don't want to just
throw that on a map,
because that map
becomes too noisy.
It also slows it down, so
performance gets affected,
so the user experience
isn't particularly great.
So what we want to
do here is we want
to make sure that our
application remains scalable.
And we want to make
sure that we have--
we can manage the
data that we have.
So why don't we switch to
the Subway Locator here,
and you can see it.
Again, we have a custom style.
We're here near
Brooklyn at the moment.
So I can zoom out and give
you a little bit more data
about the subway
stations themselves.
Let me zoom back in, and I
want you to look at something.
I'm going to zoom--
I want you to look at
the top left of this map.
As I pan the map and let go
of my camera, so I'm panning
and let going, it goes and
populates the subway stations.
That's the back-end
doing its job.
So the way that this
application works
is that as the camera
moves, we go and say,
give me my viewport.
Go fetch the stations that are
in my viewport and populate it.
So that way, we're not
overloading the map
with tons and tons of markers,
and we're still keeping
a fairly good user experience.
Of course, we've got info
windows on these subway stops,
as well, that just sort of
give the name of the place
as well as which line it's on.
And the only other
thing I want to call out
is that the map itself
has got the subway lines
already drawn on it.
That's the static
data on this map.
So let's switch
back to the slides.
And the architecture for this,
we're now adding a Google App
Engine instance,
so that stores.json
file we had for Josie's example,
that's now its own component.
And the reason is that
we need that back-end.
We want to make sure
we're scaling it out
so that we're providing
the right amount of data.
Interestingly enough, I want
you to notice that we have
a GeoJSON file here as well.
So we're still going to continue
to use GeoJSON in this example.
It's just going to
be on the server.
So let me show you what the
back-end implementation looks
like.
The first thing
we're going to do
is load the GeoJSON
into memory on startup,
into a data structure
called an Rtree.
And I'm going to show you
what that is in a second.
Then we're going to
register some API endpoints,
some handlers, so that
when the page needs
to request for the next view, we
have those handlers registered.
And then I'll show
you the implementation
of those handlers as well.
So an Rtree is just a
really nice data structure
that helps us look up
location data in a nice way,
in a spatial way.
And so what it does is it
has these minimum bounding
boxes when you give
it all the data,
and then it generates
a tree-like structure
like you see in the
bottom-right there.
So it groups these
objects in nearby--
that are near to one
another and then provides
easy look-up methods.
So that's-- you can start to see
how we are able to say, well,
in this view port, Rtree, go
and give me all the data points,
and it's optimized
for that type of data.
In terms of our App
Engine code, we've
actually written it in Go.
And the reason we're using
Go, Google's Go language,
is because you end up with a
lot of very clean code that's
easy to read and yet
is quite capable.
But App Engine supports
many different languages,
so you could use any of them.
It's just what we chose
for our implementation.
So for a Go application
in App Engine,
your initialization
method is init.
And what we're going to do
is load all of our locations
into our Rtree.
And we're using a great
implementation of an Rtree
on GitHub by DH
[? Connelly, ?] so thank you
for that if you're
here or watching.
And then what we're going to
do is register those handlers.
So you'll notice here
we say, slash data slash
subway stations, and then
we give a function name.
And then we say, slash
data slash subway lines,
and we give another
function name.
So basically, whenever we
call that particular endpoint,
that method is going
to handle it for us.
Let's have a look at what
that's going to look like.
So this is the subway
stations handler.
We're going to call
this thing by saying,
slash data slash
subway dash stations.
And we're going to provide a
viewport parameter, which says,
here's my top right and bottom
left coordinates, and so go
fetch me the
locations from that.
So you see here, we're going to
get the viewport parameter out,
and we're going to
create a rectangle.
And then because of this really
awesome Rtree implementation,
we can just easily say,
find me the intersection
of all the locations that
fit within this rectangle,
return it as a GeoJSON object.
And that's really,
really cool, because then
from our Go component, we're
sending it back as GeoJSON,
and then, of course,
on the web page,
we've got that one
line of implementation,
map.load.geojson.
Out Really, really neat.
In terms of the web side
of the implementation,
those first four are
exactly the same as what
we had with Josie's example.
We have a different style.
We have a different
latitude, longitude.
But the code is the same.
What's new is this
map idle listener.
So let's have a look at that.
What we do with the
map idle listener
is we're telling
the map that when
the camera stops
moving, when it's idle,
to call this bit of code.
And all we're doing is
getting those bounds,
the southwest coordinates and
the northeast coordinates.
And we're calling slash
data slash subway stations
and passing in that
viewport parameter,
and that's what's
going to the back-end.
But you notice that
when we call this,
we're saying
map.data.loadgeojson.
So GeoJSON is, again,
really benefiting us here,
populating the map dynamically.
It's handled very easily.
So that's actually it.
There was a bunch of boilerplate
code that I didn't show,
but again, we've
open sourced this
so you can have a look
at all of the details.
But that's the map-related code.
This there's really
not much there.
And so we have a fairly
sophisticated example
where we've got interaction
between back-end and front-end
to provide that awesome
Subway Locator with kind
of minimal overhead on us.
So we've used the
JavaScript API,
we put some custom styling in
there, and we used App Engine.
We're using Go.
All right, let's mix
things up even further.
Let's look at dynamic data.
And for the dynamic
data example,
we're going to look
at a Home Finder
Now, I've marked this as preview
because this is something
we're still working on.
But I wanted to show
you architecturally
how it's going to fit.
So I don't have a demo
specifically for this one yet,
but I just wanted to show you
how we're building this out.
And it should be fairly logical
to see how we're extending it.
So if you think about
a real estate app,
the data actually does change
reasonably frequently, right?
People are going to
post times for viewing
for a particular property.
Properties are going to come
on the market for purchase
or for leasing.
Eventually, in general--
and people may even rate it.
They'll put some
photos on there.
In general, there's going to be
a lot of change on this site.
So we want to make sure
we can handle that change.
We want to make sure that we
have a great user experience.
So if we look at the
architecture for this,
again, it's similar to the
New York Subway Locator,
but now, instead
of a GeoJSON file
that we load into
memory on startup,
we have a database so that we
can dynamically update data,
read data, and populate things.
Now we're going to use Google
Cloud SQL as our database.
It works really great
with App Engine.
And specifically,
we're using PostgreSQL.
And the reason we're
using PostgreSQL
is because PostgreSQL
has this extension called
PostGIS, which gives us
spatial access methods.
So the same type of
intersection that we
were doing with the Rtree
in the last example,
we can do with a database.
Let me show you.
So our back-end implementation
is, again, much the same
as the Subway Locator.
We'll have different
pieces of functionality.
You might have a different
handler for give me the viewing
times, or give me the
photos of this place,
and so on, but architecturally,
it's more or less the same.
You just might have a
little bit more interaction,
depending on what you
have in your info windows.
But the new bit is the database.
So rather than show you
all of the steps that
are required to
set up a database,
I wanted to keep this focused
on the Maps side of things.
There's a great guide
here that shows you
how you set up a Google
Cloud instance, Google Cloud
SQL instance with
Postgres, and then
how you connect it
using Go to App Engine.
It's not a lot of work.
It's fairly easy to follow.
So it's a great guide.
But what I really
wanted to call out
was this SQL statement here.
So when we ask the back-end
that, hey, here's my viewport.
I want you to go find me all of
the homes and apartments that
are in that particular
location, we
can do it with a
simple SQL query
like this, where we
just say, give me
all of the locations that
fit within a bounding box.
And the reason we're
able to do this
is because of that
PostGIS extension.
So it's really, really
worth checking out.
It just really simplifies
our implementation.
And of course, once that data
comes back from the table,
we're going to return it as a
GeoJSON blob to our front-end,
populate the map,
and we're good to go.
So the actual web
implementation isn't
going to change so
much, architecturally.
Yes, you're going to
have different styles.
Again, you're going to
have different markers
for specific--
whether it's a place for leasing
or a place for purchasing.
But architecturally,
it's much the same.
When the viewport changes or
the user clicks on a marker,
we're going to bring
up and inf window
with the right amount
of information.
And you'll probably
have some other HTML
elements around there as well.
Really, really simple and
really, really straightforward.
So we've now covered
three solutions.
And we're going to get
to my fourth solution
now, which is the
real-time example.
And it's-- I'm a bit biased
here, but it's my favorite one.
It's a Transport Tracker.
And the reason it's
my favorite one
is because it's all about
Google I/O, actually.
So Google I/O is actually being
held in Shoreline Amphitheater,
for those of you that
are watching online.
It's not very convenient to get
to if you're in San Francisco
or if you're flying in.
So what we did is when we
organized this conference,
we provided shuttle
buses that take you
to and from many hotels
all over the area.
What we thought would
be really useful
is to build a Transport
Tracker to track these buses.
So as attendees
here can attest to,
if you go to the registration
desk or the Maps Sandbox,
you can come and
see how long it's
going to take for your rides
to actually get to their hotels
or from their hotels.
So in this case, we have
a constant stream of data,
because our buses are constantly
reporting their location.
And we're doing
something with it.
We're going to
analyze that data.
And I'll show you what kind
of analysis we're doing,
and then we're going to do some
computation on it before we
present it to the user.
Why don't I first
show you a demo.
All right.
So this is our dashboard.
And it's not-- this dashboard
is not meant to be interactive,
because it's for attendees as
they're walking to their buses
and looking to leave.
But what you can see is we
have a number of colored boxes,
which are just the lines, the
actual bus routes that we have,
and then you can see
the markers on the map.
You see pins on the map
that match the hotels,
and we've colored them based
on the line that they're on.
And then we have the actual
bus markers, as well,
that move around as
the buses are moving.
And just so you know,
this is live data
that we're looking at.
I took the risk, and it's
working fine, so that's good.
The other thing I
want to point out
is these boxes that are coming.
These are just HTML
elements that we're drawing,
but the data there is actually
coming through the Maps APIs.
So the times that we're
giving you for estimated time
to travel to each
of these hotels,
it's actually powered
by our Directions API.
They give you estimates in
current traffic conditions.
So that's really, really cool.
This is like real-time traffic
information powering this app.
Actually, to take
it one step further,
we've got a number of buses
that don't leave right now,
but might leave in the
afternoon to go to the airport.
And we use our
predictive travel times
to give you our best guess
at traffic conditions
at that time of
the day and week.
So it's not just
real-time traffic.
You can do some
forecasting here, as well.
Please come check it
out at the Sandbox.
for those of you that are here.
And we have documentation
for those of you
that are going to follow from
your office or from home.
So let's switch
back to the slides.
So I'm super excited about
the Transport Tracker.
Now, the Transport
Tracker architecturally
is a little bit
more complicated.
It's very different to the other
three examples we looked at.
But basically, we
have Android devices.
And we wrote a
little Android app
that goes and reports their
locations to a Firebase
Realtime Database.
And the reason we chose a
Firebase Realtime Database is
because of how good it
is with synchronizing
that data across all
of the devices that
are registered for it.
So we report our location to
a Firebase Realtime Database,
but I want to share
a secret with you,
and a somewhat open secret.
Our mobile devices, no matter
which brand of device you have,
the GPS on them can be a little
bit unreliable, depending
on which area you're in.
If you're in a tunnel, if
you're in an urban environment
with lots of tall buildings,
the GPS can be inaccurate.
So even though you have a
straight road like this,
you might actually find
that the GPS reports
are saying you're up
here, up here, down here,
up here, and so on.
It might not actually show
you exactly on the map--
on the road itself.
And we solve this
problem with an API
that we call the Roads API.
And the cool thing
about the Roads API
is you just hand in your points,
your latitudes, longitudes,
and it returns you
back a different set
of points that have been
snapped to a road for you.
And we can do this because we
know that these are vehicles.
What's even cooler is if
you're on like a roundabout
or like a curved road,
and your location data
is being sampled, I don't
know, once every 15 or 30 or 60
seconds, your
actual-- and you tried
to plot that, you're going to
have these jagged lines when
you've got curved roads.
The Roads API will actually
return you additional points
in that array so that you
get a smooth, gradual curve
as you're following that road.
So it's really, really neat.
And so when I said we needed
to analyze that data earlier,
we have a Compute
Engine instance
that we've written
in Node.js, and what
we do is we read from the
Firebase Realtime Database.
We then take those locations,
snap them to a road,
and then we send them
to the Directions API
to go ahead and give
us time estimates.
And then on our web page itself,
we just present that data.
So we're just literally
reading from that same Firebase
Realtime Database showing
the position of the buses.
We have some HTML that goes
and shows the bus routes,
and so on.
Really, really fun.
So on the back-end
side of things,
what we're going to be doing
is looking at the Firebase
Realtime Database,
reading those locations,
snapping them to a road,
and then predicting
the travel times.
Let me show you what
that looks like.
The first thing I want to call
out is we're using Node.js.
And if you're using Node.js, we
have a fantastic client library
that wraps our APIs that
makes it really easy to use
the Google Maps APIs in Node.
It's so easy that once we've
initialized the client--
and you can find out how
you set it up at that link--
to use the roads API,
it's one line of code.
Literally, we call
snap to roads,
pass in a bunch of points, we
get a returned set of points.
That's how easy this
library makes it.
Just a single line of code.
So do check out
the library itself.
In terms of the directions,
we do a little bit more work
there.
So think about the route itself.
We have-- you might be starting
at Shoreline Amphitheater,
going to five hotels, and then
going to the last destination.
So you've got an origin,
you've got a destination,
and you've got all
these stops that you
need to make in the middle.
So the way we do it for
the directions request
is that we take
that first point.
We call that the origin.
The last point, we call
that the destination.
And everything in between,
we just call that a waypoint.
And the Directions API can
handle these waypoints.
So when it gives you
those time estimates,
it's actually calculating
going from point A
to point B, point B
to point C, and so on.
In fact, the response
that it gives you,
which we're going
to look at now,
breaks it up that way as well.
So again, because of our client
library that we're using,
the directions request itself
is just a single line of code
once you've created
your request.
And we're saying, give us
a response back in JSON.
So once we just go do
some error checking,
make sure that the
response was valid,
the first thing that we do is
look at the legs of our trip.
So a leg would be going
from Shoreline to hotel A.
And then the second leg
would be hotel A to hotel B.
But for each leg,
you have a number
of points that you have to
take as well, some paths.
So for each leg, we can
actually get the duration
that it takes, and we can
even draw a line if we want,
a polyline.
We can see how long it
takes per point, as well.
So let's look at a
specific leg now,
from hotel A to hotel B. We can
iterate through that here as
well, just by looking
at each point,
and then getting
the time that we
need to so we can
display that on our page
or write it back to
our Firebase Database.
So there's a bit of code here,
but if you break it apart,
it's fairly simple to follow.
We have our whole route.
We go to find each leg,
and within each leg,
you'll have a-- getting
from hotel A to B
would be turn right here,
go straight there, turn
left there, and those are our
points for each of our legs.
So we use a number of APIs.
This solution is
entirely [INAUDIBLE].
We've got the Fused Location
Provider providing the--
powering the Android
app, so that's
what we're using
to get locations
as accurately as possible.
As possible, as I said.
We're using Firebase
Realtime Database
to keep that data in real-time.
So as soon as we have
a new piece of data,
we read it from Node.js,
and then the Maps API
is providing us tons
of capabilities.
We're not just visualizing
it on a map this time,
we're using the Directions API
to get real-time or predictive
travel time information.
And we're using the Roads
API to snap it to a road.
In fact, we used the Places
API to provide information
about Shoreline or
the hotels, as well.
So that was our four
solutions that I wanted
to talk to you about today.
I hope you can see now that by
us providing a reference lounge
room for you, a reference
implementation, that you can
see how you can take
this kind of solution
and use it for whatever
use case you have.
What I also want to say is this
is something new that we're
trying, so we think
it's really useful,
but we need to hear from you.
We'd love for you to go
check out our documentation,
check out our source
code, give us feedback.
We're always listening.
And tell us what
more you'd like,
what use cases you'd like us to
look at, what other solutions
should we build for you?
Because we think that
this is quite useful,
but we need to-- we would
love to validate it.
All of these solutions
that I presented here--
the Home Finder
is not yet ready,
but the other three solutions,
you can go check them out
at developers.googl
e.com/maps/solutions.
And of course, you can check
out information about all
of our APIs at
developers.google.com/maps.
Now, this is the last
session on the Google Maps
APIs at Google I/O this year.
If you haven't been able
to attend any of the others
or you're watching online,
I've put the titles
up here so that you
can go look them up
on YouTube at a later stage.
We're also going to have office
hours at 1:30 in the office
hours section
today, so if you've
got any questions,
if you want us
to have a look at your
specific use cases,
or you want some more
information on the solutions,
please come and talk to us.
With that, I really
want to say thank you.
I'm always humbled by the
fact that you give up so much
of your time to be here.
We hope that what we are sharing
with you is useful and worth
your time.
And I'm happy to take a
handful of questions now.
So if you want to come
to the microphone,
you can ask your questions.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]